we have reached this conclusion
profits from nigerian oil was partly
cashed in by the state
but some of these oil concessions were
given to private companies namely
atlantic energy and seven energy
in so doing the money that the state was
to receive ended up in private hands
[Music]
these agreements are unconstitutional
and
illegality of that transaction
the billions of kula aluko
[Music]
i tried a couple of times to call the
aluko family but i wasn't able to talk
to them
so i thought i'd better come myself
because i'd like to interview mr aluko
can you tell me if he has a home
no he isn't
anyway i can ask
it's still winter time when i started
looking for kola aluko the oil
entrepreneur wanted by the nigerian and
british magistrates accused of having
smuggled and laundered the profits of
oil whales of his country together with
the minister of oil dasani but kola
aluko has lived for two years now in
porza in this luxury villa overlooking
lake lugano
in switzerland there is no legal actions
against him
i've asked someone and i was answered
that he is not giving interviews now
this person will tell the other ones in
dozens of offshore companies a typical
jet set life
faithful friend of hollywood stars a
yacht in the caribbean villas in
apartments between los angeles and new
york and a passion for racing cars
here he is with his racing outfit a
dream come true thanks to the kessel
team in grancia for which he raced on
important international tracks but he
does not only drive ferraris he collects
them
in the kissel garage in lugano he might
have a dozen even formula one cars for a
value of many millions in francs but
even here mouths are sewn up
excuse me i'm curious how much does such
a ferrari cost
this one is new and cost one million two
hundred thousand euro
and how much does a formula one cost
from one million to four million euro
we're proud today to announce we are
proud to announce that our company has
considerably increased the flight hours
this was made possible also thanks to
the commitment of our new partner mr
cola
aluco partner
it is 2012 when a first investment by
the billionaire become known in a swiss
company with 60 crafts and stops in all
the countries worldwide visa jet is the
biggest private fleet in the world
at the airport where i was looking for
information about the entrepreneur i was
confirmed that he lands regularly with
the visachat flights
the legal head office of this airline
company for years has been this
anonymous building but when i arrived i
found out that the company just took
flight to settle in the island of melta
so even here no trace of cola
the big plus of vistajet is the ability
to focus on the needs of the various
regions the fact that they had
experience in the middle east and
militia along with the ability to offer
customized services for nigeria it is
the same thing
the core business of this billionaire
entrepreneur is oil
to him and some of his partners one can
trace two nigerian companies seven
energy
and atlantic energy
the second besides in nigeria has a
bridge in zurich switzerland
[Applause]
good morning we are looking for atlantic
energy
i have no idea what it is
is it the one here below
it's on the fourth floor have you ever
seen anyone
no we have nothing to do with them
is this one right
ever since i've been here this floor has
been empty
branch of atlantic energy no desk no
computer nothing that leads to suppose
that someone is working here
an entire floor of a luxurious building
on the zooek lake whose rental surely
cost tens of millions of francs a month
is empty
atlantic energy does it still exist
did you try looking inside is there
furniture
no there isn't any when did they leave
actually
since i work here i've never seen anyone
how long have their offices been here
for a year
they've had their brands here for a year
and they are never here
atlantic energy there
you're looking for them right
we sometimes saw someone parking
they were africans they came and left
quickly but officially they never
actually moved
despite the fact that the offices are in
zurich atlantic energy is signed up in
the zuko commercial registry
it is officially being closed and aluko
is not in the list of shareholders as a
person in charge we found another
manager
oscar rabeshi i decided to look for him
at his home
i'm looking for mr mabishi
i don't know him
i live over there
but when i arrive i can hardly believe
what i see
the president of the board of directors
of atlantic energy a billionaire company
lives in this modest apartment on the
outskirts
nobody is in here alright let's move
may i ask you something
do you know the mobichi family
okay
[Music]
so
good morning
i'm looking for seven energy
good morning i am looking for seven
energy i am from swiss television i'd
like to know if i can meet someone from
seven energy
energy
are these sevens headquarters am i in
the right place can you at least give me
mr cola aluko's number
i can reach mr cola
caller aluko
i have no number i don't
is in london
the other oil company bringing to the
entrepreneur and his partners
what should be the international branch
of a company with a billionaire budget
is no more than a small office on the
fourth floor victorian building
the only person there is the secretary
much to my surprise she never heard of
kola aluko
aluko even inaugurated a charity
foundation in his name in london
in the attempt to find it i reached by
phone a former advisor of this
foundation
on those two times i met mr aluko i saw
a person who told me i want to do it
because i am a nigerian and i want to
give back my fortune part of my personal
fortune to nigeria for youngsters who
are in need this was the real and noble
objective of this project i don't really
know what was behind it
as i found out from this call the ghost
foundation with legal office in
linchestein went out like a meteor right
from the start
without ever giving one single pound in
charity
what types of problem were there did the
foundation only last for a single year
i think what happened is that the
foundation had some sort of
inauguration in london then i think
there was a moment of blackout due to
the change of government and the scandal
that took place with giving oil
concessions to nigeria
a touch of a magic wand he then turned
into a high level oil magnate thanks to
contracts made with seven energy and
atlantic energy
energy
energy and in atlantic energy
in downtown london i met the nigerian
anti-corruption activist who for various
non-government organizations had carried
out meticulous research on this matter
his report to the united kingdom d.a
office had the spotlights of the press
turned to what is considered one of the
greatest laundering cases of the world
[Music]
that were to give to the state
this type of diversion of funds could
not have taken place without the
complicity of high-level government
officials
[Music]
so what is quite evident is that
is a dummy but he is neither the owner
nor the beneficiary of the
the company activist tells me about the
real fraud that began to take place
around 2010 when a nigerian state oil
company granted its license to some oil
fields to private companies
the lots all go without any tender to
seven energy and atlantic energy
both related to cola
the reason for this choice remains a
mystery
atlantic energy
was not performing any function
at the time when atlantic energy was
given the license the company carried
out no activity and was only two months
old
in much the same way seven energy was a
front company
totally void of a clear financial past
apart from that it must be said that
these companies have not paid anything
for those licenses
the money coming from oil profits were
to go into the state treasury but all
this money was simply smuggled elsewhere
hundreds of millions of dollars
hundreds and millions of dollars
there are three legal opinions which
confirm that these agreements are
unconstitutional and illegal
it was 2014 when the case exploded in
nigeria
in the live tv program the governor of
the central bank reported 20 billion
dollars missing from the state treasury
and he points the spotlight to the
illegitimate agreements between the
state oil company and the two other
companies
the accusations are blow right at the
oil minister
thank you again i want to stress that
you know there are different views
there are different interpretations of
the legality of these things
has
a deduction of subsidy at source as a
first-line charge
the minister of oil
who is now undergoing an investigation
here in the united kingdom for the
diversion of funds through oil
agreements along with a series of other
accusations the
strategic
alliance
aluco is considered the dummy of the
minister and of some high-ranking
government executives including possibly
jonathan former nigerian president are
involved including possibly jonathan the
former president
when i returned to lucano i took a good
look at the situation the dynamics of
this matter are appallingly bono the
minister and her dummy would be the
accomplices in smuggling the profit of
billions coming from oil whales
as a matter of fact the nigerian oil
company controlled by the minister
grants eight licenses to seven in
atlantic
the money for the oil extraction which
in the past would go to the state
treasury now disappears in the saves of
the two companies
billions properly laundered in our
country too
i am a journalist from rsi
i have been waiting for weeks for the
mayor to call me back
this is where aluko resides and pay
taxes
i have lost hope
i decided to personally go to town hall
which is a few steps away from the oil
magnates villa the mayor is not there
but they have me talk to him on the
phone
i don't know to what extent you are
informed on this matter
it doesn't involve you personally but it
involves your municipality also because
i believe this person
you're telling me is you must respect
privacy and that you're not interested
in what is going on
we are talking about billions being
laundered i'm talking about billions of
dollars
you as a municipal authority are not
interested
all right i can only acknowledge the
fact that you are not interested and i
thank you
authoritaria
foreign
you
we don't have to go
to 360 degrees
now it's time we go
the 180.
i want to see the impact of corruption
on people's lives with my own eyes see
what it means to live in one of the
world's most corrupted countries that
for years was systematically plundered
where the luxury of the buildings of
those corrupted shadows the hungers
it is not my first trip to africa
but the impact is devastating
on paper according to what economists
say nigeria because of its oil fields is
the richest country of africa
and yet 120 million people equal to 70
of the population live here with less
than two dollars a day
i cannot believe that in a country
reduced to famine nobody is interested
in cola alucos billions
corruption makes people poorer
makes each nigerian poorer
it takes access to electricity away it
is hard to put a meal together nigeria
actually had to increase its gas prices
the population has suffered greatly and
continues to do so even now that i am
here talking to you
[Music]
people who have stolen the resources and
money of the country
damaging millions of nigerians to go and
have a good life abroad
they see them as non-patriotic people as
people who get rich exploiting others
who live in extreme poverty
in the midst of
huge poverty in the country
the oil sector will be more corrupt
people now see us the oil sector is the
most corrupted it is seen as a road to
make easy money
it is the highest paid work in nigeria
there have having salaries that went
beyond the average level globally
even some ministers and parliament
members uses this road to grab the oil
whales and do business themselves or
pass it on to their friends
a person can become as rich as a state
while damaging millions of nigerians
millions of nigerians
in the delta of the
river oils of the companies
where there are niger
but it is impossible
during my stay a series of attacks hit
some pipelines but then it is in the
capital city that power is
concentrated this appalling case of
fraud and recycling
a little over a year ago a new executive
group has taken over
elected with the objective of fighting
corruption a new president is determined
to recuperate these billions of dollars
smuggled by kola aluko and his partners
and other people and companies
presumably fund companies were accused
of laundering illicit diversion of
public funds and economical crimes
against nigeria
this is what is written in an injunction
that freezes the assets
and that these assets were acquired or
obtained
in fact while i was here the nigerian
national court issued a freezing order
for kola aluko's assets and those of
atlantic energy spread out throughout
the world
from the united states to great britain
and switzerland for 1.7 billion dollars
in the list as far as our country is
concerned there are dozens of accounts
in four swiss credit institutes for over
67 million francs
58 luxury cars three private planes
and a land area of over 000 square
meters at montanola in tecino
this is a core measure recognized by the
entire world
it is an asset freezing injunction it
deals with assets in nigeria and abroad
meaning even assets in switzerland
wherever they may be including those in
montanola
as far as kola aluko is concerned we
expect cooperation in the restitution of
assets taken and brought to switzerland
we ask for restitution of investments
aluko made in switzerland
i must admit that switzerland was very
cooperative but we want to see more
cooperation in an unconditioned
restitution of assets
good morning i am calling you because we
have talked about mr kola aluko having
acquired your land
i want to know if they intended to do
something after the conversation request
of the montanola land
you haven't been informed yet
it was in all the newspapers did you
discuss it at the town hall council
you know nothing about it
it is an important matter
all right
okay okay
one of the problems is that sometimes
one of the problem is that we are often
given the bill by western countries for
the restitution of assets
they say it has costs
sometimes we feel offended because they
ask us for 20 or more
or even more
and
this has been proven by
as confirmed by a report of the world
bank only a small part of assets
smuggled returns to the country of
origin
because the developed countries use any
excuse to keep the money
they have conferences and take all the
right resolutions but never act in a
positive sense
i think it is time to change
[Music]
uh
when the fight against corruption was to
be faced the international community did
nothing for a long time
the international community must
facilitate the return of smuggled assets
we estimated that illicit activity in
the oil sector makes us lose seven
billion dollars a
dollars year year
[Applause]
it is may 10 2016 when in london the
nigeria president attends the
international summit on corruption from
the convention once again many
declarations of intent were manifested
among the guests even didier buckhalter
swiss foreign minister avoiding that
this money comes to us but if the money
but if the money keeps arriving to us
anyway
and it does we must do everything we can
so that this money be returned to its
illegitimate owners to the people of
poor countries
what will the financial system of the
developed markets do to assist nigeria
in trying to recuperate those billions
but also to make sure that this will not
be repeated in the future
alongside the london summit i met an
analyst who studied in detail the
corruption impact on nigerian economy he
believed there is much hypocrisy in the
western financial sector
of corruption would increase by the year
2030 the average ngp to 2 000 per
inhabitant
i think the most important question is
what has been the role of the
international financial system in this
matter
it is difficult to smuggle capital by
oneself
if someone wants to have money in
switzerland he or she needs financial
partners who make this transfer easy
and unfortunately i believe as we go
deep into the matter that were too many
so-called developed world partners
willing to facilitate these transfers
without the necessary verification
but it appeared to me that there was no
police it seems that there is no
political will in the western world to
investigate on financial mediators that
cooperated with seven energy
there is a world bank agency there is a
fund financed by almost all european
cooperation agencies that had the duty
of verifying that they were investing in
fair commercial operations
that they are engaging in bona fide
businesses
so questions have to be
there are serious doubts on all these
international investors who invested in
seven energy
what did they do
to assert that seven energy has acquired
those contracts correctly
i turned these serious doubts to the
agencies that invested in seven
but never received an answer
but then even though swiss bank named in
confiscation order did not express
themselves
nor did fema the swiss control
institution
thus i will never know how many millions
or better yet
billions were presumably laundered in
switzerland by kola aluko
good morning i'm looking for a land area
of about 000 square meters it must have
been sold here in montenella to a
nigerian oil magnate
can you tell me approximately where it
is
good thing there are people who have
money to spend people who buy and sell
they said it's enormous and not far from
the american school
no further up
[Music]
it's summer time
when i managed to locate the land
alucobot over 2 000 square meters of
building overlooking the lake lugano
who knows how many other investments
were made undisturbed in our country
despite an international regulatory was
issued in burn against the oil magnates
in switzerland
no legal procedure
in july the villa
was abandoned
is
it is clear that he must give answers if
he can defend himself okay but if he
can't
law will follow his course and do
justice
part of that money could have financed
schooling for thousands of nigerians
from elementary school to middle school
without them spending one cent
a first-class hospital could have been
built
in every federal state of nigeria we
could have built about 1 000 kilometers
you must unconditionally return all
assets and help nigeria come out of
poverty
[Music]
so
you